c'est toujours un moment délicat pour
les parents le jour où leurs enfants
leur demande comment on fait un bébé des
explications sur la sexualité
si cela vous arrive dans les jours à
venir n'hésitez pas foncez à la cité des
sciences où une exposition très drôle
intitulé le villi sexuelle répondre à
toutes leurs questions
il y à une machine à déclaration d'amour
une essoreuse à laon pour apprendre à
embrasser et toutes les explications sur
l'acné mari elle est bonne au frédéric
bazille un sujet tabou abordé de façon
ludique et rigolote pour les 9-14 ans la
sexualité raconter aux enfants est
d'abord un sentiment l'amour tout
commence par la rencontre la proche et
les premiers baisers nous apprendre tout
sur l'amour et cetera gueule déjà son
âme
elle
l'amour la première fois titeuf des
complète la situation avec des dessins
inédits de les eps mais avant de passer
à l'acte
on explique les caresses le corps de
l'autre est à manier avec précaution
comme cette machine d'accord
c'est mais après il s'est habillé pour
monter cette exposition délicate
il a fallu travailler étroitement avec
les enfants on avait envie de faire une
sorte de lunapark autour de la sexualité
on a quand même dire des choses qui sont
qui sont précises donc
on devait toujours ménager ces deux
choses quoi la fois être rigoureux et
puis en même temps être le plus
imaginatif fois ci les transformations
du corps sont abordés et les
comportements publics de l'enfant à
partir d'un certain âge ou logistique
est ce que c'est on dise que c'est la
puberté et que ces deux là c'est pour ma
part il entraîna tafas par grin dix
autres découvert le foetus
ce qu'ils aiment et ce qu'ils n'aiment
pas et pour finir les mises en garde
bref tout ce que vos enfants ou toujours
voulu savoir sur le sexe sans jamais
oser vous le demande et ils le
trouveront ici